oh my god
katie's uh in the living room and she's
like what's going on and like go
downstairs you could just hear the
droning noise and that's when she
noticed the ear popping sensation as
we're going down the stairs it just
like we're on an airplane yeah it's
crazy yes
it was like we were taking off you know
when you take off and you land and we're
trying to run around and get our kids
and get in the storage room trying not
to panic for them but we've never
experienced this before so it was
scary and it just the droning kind of
wind blowing noise was uh pretty crazy
but it was like three minutes later is
when i come back outside and see the
roof is
torn off on the corner the last 12 hours
have been some of the most difficult
times
of our our community has faced we are
strong committed to coming together in
times of need
the national weather service determined
the tornado that tore through our
community was estimated to be an ef-3
with wind speeds between 136 miles and
155 miles per hour we have approximately
52 damaged or destroyed homes in the
path of tornado that spanned over 13.7
miles
at this time we have six confirmed
fatalities from three different
residents
the names of the victims are melissa
beasley 63
rodney clark 64. cecilia lloyd 72
michael bolger 37 and kenley vulgar five
and owen bogler two we also have six
victims still being treated for their
injuries
talk about the number of volunteers that
i saw
200 to 300 iowans not only from madison
county and winterset but from
communities and towns all across the
state that were on the ground the minute
it was light and they could start
helping
and
it's just unbelievable i tried to walk
through and thank them for being there
and over and over the response was we're
iowans and that's what we do
we show up we take care of our family we
take care of our neighbors and we take
care of our community
you